And, everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters.
In this video, I want to go over our cancer plan.
So, when most people come to us,
they're looking for help with cancer.
Now, we do help people with Lyme disease
and other things, too.
Go to the bottom of this page
if you're on our website
and you can go to our sister site that applies to that.
But the majority of people that we're taking care of
are people with a diagnosis of cancer.
Now, we offer a lot of things.
So, people come to us and they have financial concerns.
They have, there's information on this website.
We also have our courses that you can join.
And our flagship, what about cancer?
Is to stop fighting cancer and start treating the cause.
And that's based on my book.
Now, this is the last edition of the book.
Our new edition is going to look a little bit different.
We haven't completely finalized the cover.
But that's actually coming out January of 2026.
So, that's a 600 page book with a lot of details
on how you could take care of your cancer
from an alternative perspective
working through that yourself.
But we're a clinic.
So, we help people work through that.
So, the main way that people come to us
with a diagnosis of cancer is to do our plan.
That includes a lot of things.
I'll go over just a smidgen of those on this video.
But we do believe that education is the key.
So, you'll see, I've made thousands of videos.
Now, I understand you don't have time to go through all those.
That's why we hold your hand through our cancer plan.
So, it includes access to membership sites
and things like that.
That is different than what you have just on this website.
Well, we believe in teaching.
That's a big part of what I believe my purpose is here.
God has given me wisdom.
I pray for wisdom for you individually,
but I pray for wisdom in how to take care of people collectively.
And then I'm supposed to share that wisdom.
So, I make videos and like this.
And like the ones you'll see on our website
and on our video site, thousands of them
to try to educate people the best.
Take care of themselves no matter what their problem is.
With our cancer plan, we do a lot of things
to dignify the cause.
So, we're gonna do testing.
So, there's gonna be initial cheek swab testing
that we'll do to help put together
your initial nutritional and dietary protocol.
But we also do toxicity testing.
So, we're gonna be doing different toxicity tests
based upon you as an individual.
Not everybody gets the exact same tests,
but we'll plan those tests, whatever labs,
there might be blood tests, there might be saliva tests,
there might be stool sample tests, whatever we're gonna do
to help dignify that cause to put together
the most exclusive and perfect protocol for you.
Every single person is different.
That's the key.
And we need to try to dig and root out that cause
and so that we can get to the root of the problem
and be treating that.
Not just trying to get the cancer to go away,
but trying to get your body to work correctly.
So, that's what our initial,
what we call our complete initial workup is.
It's a little bit different for each person,
depending on what we talk about at the case review
and what I determined,
what is gonna be best to help dig to that cause.
Also, with our cancer plan,
you have access to our full membership site,
which includes our Zoom call.
So those are really key.
So you do get discounted one-on-ones with me.
You also get a bunch of included one-on-ones with me.
Those are, there be over the folder, over Zoom,
to go over, you know, how to use your right machine,
to go over what we found on the cheek swab testing,
to go over what we found on the toxicity testing
and how we're gonna tweak your plan
and we took over your genetic testing.
We're gonna go, that's all included.
But you also get, you know,
steeply discounted office visits
if you just need to talk to me about something.
But one of the ways we help decrease the costs
of the office visits is we have weekly Zoom calls.
So you have a weekly Zoom call.
Currently, it's every Wednesday at four o'clock central time.
You could jump on the Zoom call
and ask questions directly.
It's a live Zoom call.
Goes for about an hour.
You get to listen to other people's questions too.
They say, oh, I didn't even have that question.
Now that really makes a lot of sense.
So there's some good intermingling that goes on
that could really be helpful.
Also, if you can't get on at that time,
you can on the member site,
you can post your question.
So then it goes on the weekly member Zoom call
and it will be part of the PowerPoint presentation
anonymously.
So you don't have to share your like story
to people you don't want to.
So those questions are all anonymous
and I'll go over the answers to those.
Now there's occasions that your personal problem
is needing to one-on-one visit with me.
Those prices are steeply discounted as a full member.
I did mention the private full membership site.
That's a totally different website
with a ton of information that we don't give out
to the public.
It's a private site.
That's where you and all the Zoom calls will be posted.
They're recorded.
So if you can't listen to them live,
they're all recorded and you can listen to them
and get your answer that may be a question
that you had posted afterwards.
So it's typically posted right after the Zoom call.
We have a ton more information on that site
that is not out to the public.
So that's highly beneficial that member site.
Also included in our cancer plan is a rife machine
because that's really what these started
and taking care of people with cancer a long time ago.
Gosh, back in the late 90s.
Gosh, we're going on 30 years of doing this.
So currently we use the Atelier Robin
and it's our personal edition of the Atelier Robin
is what we use.
That is, to me, the best rife machine on the market.
If you're like, I don't know what a rife machine is.
I have a whole page on our website
about why we love rife technology.
Again, this is what got me into taking care
of cancer patients in the very beginning.
Had a cancer patient come in with breast cancer
in both breasts was given three months to live.
Started using a rife with her
and doing some nutritional things, what I do then,
which was a fraction of what I don't know.
And she lived another 13 years, still okay.
So pretty good results there.
Every patient that we've really worked with
since then has gotten a rife machine.
And I think this is the best one out of the market right now.
Uses a level of harmonic frequency
since lots of reasons for it
and I have more information on the rife page about that.
So everybody's going to have that working for them,
typically they're using that at night while they sleep
so that they can live during the day.
We have some patients that use it during the day as well.
But I write all the programs that are on there
and there's programs for just whatever thing
you can think of.
So we highly suggest you use this for the rest of your family
if they come down with a cold or something like that too.
Do you want to be using rife technology?
It's a key component to all sorts of healing.
And then we do a full genetic workup.
This is totally different than what you got at your oncologist
so they did genes.
This is a 380 page summary report.
And then we do two other reports that come with it
that summarize your positive findings
and then an action step report.
And I'll go over this with you personally.
Takes about an hour to go over everything
we need to go over once we get your genetic report back.
Now this is key.
This is very important because many times
I don't really believe that genetics are the cause of cancer.
But when you have genetic defects in tumor suppressor genes,
when you have genetic defects in detoxification genes,
it can be a big piece of why.
The reason why you got that.
And we're always digging to the why, right?
That's the whole thing.
That's why I wrote the book Stop Fighting Cancer
and start treating the cause.
Digging to that why?
If we can change the blue of your body,
we can help mitigate the effects of genetic defects.
If we can detoxify correctly and we can attack the cancer
with rife technology and good nutrition,
you're going to have the best results.
Even if you do choose to do some standards of care too,
it's very complimentary.
So nothing we are going to recommend
is going to be against standards of care.
So they can work together wonderfully,
but we need to dig to that reason why
and be addressing that,
you're definitely going to get the best results.
We also know that God is our healer, right?
So we're in prayer over our patients.
It's a big piece of what we do.
We trust God in all things.
We ask for prayers for wisdom
because it is God's wisdom that's going to lead us
in right understanding and give us peace in all the decisions
that we make.
Pray for you now,
whether you decide to come on board with us or not,
know that you're in our prayers and we care for you.
God bless you.
Bye-bye.